[Musique]
michel cherche un endroit où stationner
sa voiture
il pense en avoir trouvé un ici près de
l'intersection
mais non le grosses bandes jaunes sur le
coin indique que c'est interdit
il trouve finalement une place sur un
autre coin de rue où il n'y a pas de
bandes jaunes et 10 garçons auto puis va
faire ses courses à son retour une
mauvaise surprise l'attend une
contravention parce que l'auto est
stationné trop près de l'intersection
michel est furieux contrairement à
l'autre coin rue il n'y a rien ni bandes
jaunes ni panneau alors pourquoi une
contravention parce que le code de la
sécurité routière interdit le
stationnement à moins de cinq mètres
d'une intersection
on veut ainsi protéger les piétons et il
n'est pas nécessaire de tout indiquée ce
qui est dans le code
le fin mot de l'histoire quand ça
concerne le code de la sécurité routière
pas besoin de le voir il faut le savoir